رئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك حاول الاسبوع
الماضي طمانه الكونغرس بانه بيانات 150
مليون امريكي على المنصه لن تنقل للحكومه
الصينيه ووسط المطالبات بحظر التطبيق
امريكيا بحثت جون الامكانيه القيام بذلك
الصحيفه اشارت الى ان واشنطن لديها مجموعه
من الادوات الاقتصاديه الا ان جهود الحظر
تواجهها تحديات قانونيه قبل ثلاثه اعوام
حاول رئيس الامريكي حينها دونالد ترامب
حظر تيك توك بامر تنفيذي الا ان قضيين
اتحاديين قال لا انه ما من سلطه لدى
الرئيس للقيام بذلك
لكن الان بامكان واشنطن سن قوانين كما
يجري حاليا في الكونجرس لمنح الرئيس صراحه
سلطه حظر برامج معينه فيما عدا ذلك كيف
سيتم الحظر هذا هو السؤال بمقدور الولايات
المتحده الضغط على
الشركه الام للتيك توك من اجل بيع التطبيق
لشركه غير صينيه ايضا يمكن للولايات
المتحده اغلاق المنافذ امام شركه تمارس
انشطه تجاريه في الولايات المتحده ومنعها
من التعامل مع تيك توك كذلك تستطيع
الاداره اذا ما شرعت القوانين حرمان تيك
توك من الوصول الى البنوك والمعلنين في
الولايات المتحده ومن الحلول ايضا ان تجبر
الاداره شركه جوجل وابل على حذف التطبيق
من متاجر التطبيقات وهو اجراء لا سابق له
لكن جميع هذه الخطوات قد تثير قلقا كبيرا
في اوساط الشباب خاصه من سيطره التطبيقات
الصينيه على قائمه اكثر التطبيقات التي
يهتم بها الشباب في الولايات المتحده
التطبيقات الصينيه تغزو قلوب الشباب
الامريكيين
في الاسابيع الثلاثه الاولى من هذا الشهر
اربعه من اكثر خمسه تطبيقات تحميلا صينيه
المنشا
تطبيق تيمو للتسوق الالكتروني تطبيق حديث
عمره سبعه اشهر هو التطبيق الاكثر تحميلا
عبر متاجر التطبيقات في الولايات المتحده
في المركز الثاني تطبيق كاب كات لتعديل
الفيديو وهو تابع للتيك توك
في المركز الثالث تطبيق تيك توك
[موسيقى]
متجر تجزئه الازياء شي ان حل في المركز
الرابع
في المركز الخامس جاء فيسبوك وهو التطبيق
الوحيد غير الصيني من بين الخمسه الاوائل
[موسيقى]